[Music]
eleven-year-old powerhouse singer
Angelica Hale back on the AGT stage
hitting those high notes this time for
America's Got Talent the champions what
does it feel like when you get to hit
those high notes and then not only do
that but impress the judges
[Music]
we met Angelica in 2017 during season 12
of egt she was guest judge Chris
Hardwick's golden buzzer America
immediately fell in love with the young
girl with the big voice and her
inspiring story when I was 4 years old
making me stop working my mom was a
match and she gave me her kidney and it
was a successful surgery Angelica
finished in second place this time she's
got her eyes on that number one spot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
turns out in jela cos fight song paint
off in a big way I can do anything I'm
gonna help you win this
[Applause]
[Music]
are you hyper critical now that your
only get that one golden buzzer more
nervous than critical because if I'm
gonna give somebody a golden buzzer I
know there's somebody that is also
included in champions coming up next so
my concern is if I hit it now did I
waste it that I have to give it to
somebody else who needs it more than the
person I gave it to is a lot it's a
different thought pressure on you sounds
like Hali really it's a ton of pressure
I don't know how I do it of course the
episode had many other standout talents
like six-year-old DJ arch who won South
Africa's Got Talent in 2015 when he was
just three
[Applause]
and illusionist Darcy oak who had a
little help from Howie Mandel when he
seemingly got Heidi Klum to float in the
air
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]